[MUSIC PLAYING]
You might have seen the other
film, and you know that I'm
interested in tether dynamics.
And part of that is flying kites
and doing experiments.
But in those experiments, I need
to know where the tether
is, and what it's
doing over time.
And it's easy to see the
tether from here.
It's nice and black and
fairly visible.
But from way far away, so that
we can see the entire tether,
it gets a bit difficult to see
what this line is doing.
So we're going to need to do
something about that in terms
of image processing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think we could probably
get the whole kite.
So we're going to set up the
cameras in two directions,
because we want to record the
dynamics of what the kite
string is actually doing.
And from the pictures, we're
going to try to find the
tether in the sky.
So it's quite cloudy, so it
will be quite difficult.
But hopefully, with some clever
algorithms and image
processing, we can find out
where the tether is and what
it's doing over time.
So on the video camera, you
might not actually be able to
see the line, because it's
lower resolution.
But hopefully on the skills,
we'll be able to work out sort
of where the line is just based
on averaging different
directions over time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm going to connect this
camera up with the other
camera with this wire.
And they're both connected
to a trigger.
And with the trigger, they'll
both shoot at the same time.
So we'll get one picture
every second.
And from that, hopefully, we
can work out some dynamics.
There's a limit to the frequency
you can work out
with one picture per second, but
at this point, we're going
to give it a try.
OK, so I can't take credit for
a lot of the hard work that
went into this project.
There's a master's student,
Richard Shaw, and he did a lot
of work for his master's
figuring out how you could
find a tether on a background of
clouds, or trees, or all of
those kind of things.
And he came up with a really
clever method, in terms of
image processing, to
find this tether.
And he runs around in
the rain a lot.
It is really starting to rain.
Like everything, you can't
really control the weather.
So we're going to try to get
some really quick shots in
here, and then pack
everything up.
So the kite's flying.
Hopefully, we don't have any
lightning or thunder.
Looks like the kite's
in the image.
Starting to rain a lot.
Is it ready, is it
set up, Richard?
Are we good to go?
Richard, are we ready?
Yeah, we're ready.
I can hear them in
the distance.
So you can hear the camera
going about every second.
Click, click, click.
And it's nice and wet.
OK, so I think that's enough
standing around in the rain.
Hopefully we have
some good shots.
We can go analyse them on the
laptop and see if we got
anything useful, and can see
where this tether is on this
very cloudy, rainy sky.
Different problem.
Why that and not that?
So maybe we should increase
this, because then it'll, even
if it diverges incorrectly,
the angle that we'll look
within might find it again.
No, that doesn't work.
Try cropping the kite out.
I think it's where it goes wrong
here, straightaway, and
then it just keeps going on.
Yeah, that's probably true.
We've come inside and taken
refuge from the rain.
We're a little bit wet, but in
true Cambridge fashion, it's
now sunny outside.
We've uploaded some of the
photos, and we're doing a
little bit of analysis.
We're playing around with
different parameters to see if
we can, indeed, find the tether
in this image that
really just looks like
a bunch of clouds.
So this is the original image.
And here we have what we've
been able to find.
So we've been able to find
the bottom of the tether.
You can see the tether is
actually right there, but it
starts to diverge a little bit
right at the top, right where
the kite is.
So that's not ideal.
So we're going to try playing
around with a few more
parameters and see if we can,
indeed, find the whole tether.
Could you reduce the
number of points?
I mean, increase the
number of points.
That it's averaging?
Yeah.
Uh, no.
Increase the number of points.
Ah, that it's averaging.
Control-Z that and increase
the angle, two, four, two.
Hopefully it works, Oh.
Oh, no.
No.
Hmm, it just goes wrong
right there.
This is the boring bit of
sitting in front of a computer
and looking at code.
That might help.
Disaster.
It's not a disaster.
75% of it is good.
Four or two?
Four.
Let's try four.
Hey, there we go.
Success.
OK, so the bar's getting
a little busy now.
We've been here for a while.
But we have managed to get this
programme to work, and
we've found the tether.
So this is our original image.
You can see the kite in the
top right-hand corner.
And it's really hard.
If you don't know where
the tether is, you
can't really see it.
But with the programme, if I
just run it quickly, it's
going to try to find
that image.
So what the programme
is doing--
see, it's already found it.
It was actually pretty quick.
And you can see now it's
spotted that tether.
So we found the tether in this
image, even though it's all
cloudy and there's
this background.
So what the programme is doing
is it's sort of breaking it up
into horizontal chunks, and
then running a filter.
And this philtre runs at a bunch
of different angles,
because we know the tether
is going to lie in
one of those angles.
So even if we can't see the
tether at one point, because
there's clouds in the
background, and different
tones, along one sort of line
there's going to be a peak, a
spike, in the intensity
of the pixels.
So we do that for the entire
image, running it up and down
the entire thing in
these chunks.
And then, where we have the
highest one, that's where we
actually start.
So we pick that point,
and then from that
point, work up and down.
And then we need only to look
within a certain distance and
a certain angle from the
spot that we found.
So this programme will be really
useful in terms of
experimental validation.
With two cameras looking at
this, we can find the tether
in 3D and work out
the dynamics.
I don't need to attach
any sensors to the
actual cable itself.
And I can get dynamic
response.
So it's really useful.
I'm pretty proud of this
entire programme.
It's really exciting and it will
be really useful for my
Ph.D.
[MUSIC PLAYING]